it's like even like I said it doesn't
seem like a big deal there's that I'm on
the YouTuber singing the doors but it is
a video because you can't do that like
no I mean I'm licensed I have all my
dad's copyrights Everything James
Morrison is who my father was he's not
actually Jim Morrison he was James
Morrison
um I'm Jim Morrison
he uh all his copyrights and all
everything I own his portion of the
doors as well
so like right now I can start a matter
of fact Gwen sent me a thing that says
that we're going to be torn at the end
of the year I don't know we'll see
So you you're saying your father was my
father my father my birth my father if I
was Jim Morrison James Douglas Martin
yes I was born Jim Morrison Jr my mother
I don't even know how long my mother was
a belly dancer
she was at the show October 23rd 1969
Philadelphia 40 weeks to the day I was
born later she she told me when I was
younger you know but they never
mentioned it again so I always knew but
um at any rate
so I got shot in the face in 2001 they
called me Bullet Head I did an album so
it's Bullet Head Jim Moore Jim Wilson Jr
AKA bullet head but right now IMDb Pro
and my Wikipedia they're all putting
together the Jim Morrison Junior thing
so if you if you search me Jim Morrison
Jr or I'm mostly on the Jim Morrison
you're a shot in the head I was shot in
the face yeah back in 2002. in
Philadelphia yeah is that over I someone
tried to carjack me my car by the 79
that I just tried they tried taking it
anymore it wasn't they won't get it so
and and you said your your wife is yeah
it's Gwen Gwen Stefani yes it is if you
go on
if you if you go in and just Google Jim
Morrison wants to find you go through
those images and you keep clicking on
you'll see where her working don't
forget to forget about the other guy
yeah she's my wife she told me this she
would see what happened was We were
supposed to get married when in 2017
I was so I I'd uh gotten arrested for
smashing windows out of a car on Rodeo
Drive with my skateboard what had
happened prior to that this car tried to
run me up you're currently homeless
right now I am yes yeah and Gwen's aware
of it yeah because they they cut all my
all my uh on my my uh military Pantry
got called off Gwen put like 93 000 in
the account for me that 47.47 million
dollar net worth Gwen has that cheese he
controls that but because of the fact
that isn't she married to somebody but
Blake Shelton supposed to but she's not
no she's this is what she told me the
other day uh this is what this is what
happened I was in prison then or I was
in jail what happened was she wanted it
to be special for us to get married so
if you look at the date she's married to
him it's July 3rd 2021 which is my dad's
50th anniversary of his death she would
have never married him and plus he's gay
so the thing is I mean Gavin was gay but
he's gay too but the point is he was a
standard that's why if you if you look
there was only 30 people at our wedding
she didn't make a big deal of it you
know what I mean and she just told me
the other day she's just going to go
public with it but if there is there is
pictures online that I came across that
have Gwen Stefani Morrison on her
Wikipedia she goes by that sometimes all
right so Jim Tell me uh where you grew
up I grew up in Philadelphia outside of
Philadelphia right matter of fact it's
close to where Pink's from Pink
real well he's a good friend of mine
he's from the same same spot
um so I was born in yeah King of Prussia
Pennsylvania Norristown whereas the
hospital and you were you were I assume
not raised by Jim Morrison no no he was
dead he had died I was raised by several
several people my mom repetitively got
married got kept getting married kept
having me adopted so see what it was
just oh it was a bit better yet let me
just get two so she was at the show
October 23rd 1969 in Philadelphia he had
gotten a lot back then that that like
two-month span they were in Philadelphia
New York a lot the doors my dad was
getting shows were getting canceled and
all so a lot but he did this October
23rd 1969 show did go down in
Philadelphia how old are you I'm 52 52.
yep
um so I didn't come I was going to come
out with this years ago on a matter of
fact when I was in high school I seen
Glenn I I was in high school right after
high school I see no doubt I was like
man I got to get with this check because
I knew who I was I figured I'd just run
out of California hit with these guys
you know what I mean but what happened
was I had kids I got married all this
[__] and then um and then I decided to
do the fifth year anniversary so I came
out in 2017 just to check because I've
been in that a few times matter of fact
in o5 when I was out here the the owner
of the Rainbow Room the whiskey and the
Roxy was Mario I forget his last name
but his son Michael who owns it now
because Mario died told me one day he
come he came up to me in 05 and I was
out there with let me kill my shirt
tomorrow he says uh bullet give me I
want to tell you something I said what's
that he says you know I feel responsible
for killing your mother now listen to
this I said I said what do you mean he
said when I was 13 Janice had come in
here and my father told me to put
occasion so uncomfort in the trunk and
she died that night so what do you talk
about so I didn't hear nothing about
that Janice being my mother again until
a month ago the management the Estate
Management Jeff champose his name his
son approached me it's a rainbow room up
here in Hollywood he said hey man my dad
uh
my dad uh managed your Estates your mom
and dad's estate so as Jim Janice he's
yeah it's your guys you're Jeffrey's
case yeah I said well you need to tell
Jeff like your dad first of all I
apologize for yelling at him and [__]
all you do but there's 20 million
dollars missing from the estate I don't
even care about that my point is don't
don't shun me because of it you know
what I mean so so you're you're saying
your father is Jim Morrison yes your mom
James Marshall my mother is Karen
hilinski Lee hilinski it's even going to
remember but now they're saying that she
was a surrogate
for Janice and Janice absolutely and I
see I just like Jonathan I said I sound
just like Mom I always thought I look
like a mom too missing my mom like that
Janice Joplin anyway but I have Karen
Valencia and Amy as well and your wife
is Glenn Stefani Renee Stefani Morrison
all right so and you've done some prison
time yeah I did absolutely and then yeah
so
all right smashed this window did this
car try to run me over skateboarding
down to uh from Hollywood it's time I
wasn't homeless I just got I've only
been homeless for like a month now
anyway he wasn't supposed to be coming
to get me so it was scanning from Paloma
but they're making a joke of everything
and it is funny they know I'm not I'm
not hurting out here they know that they
know I'm resourceful but the thing is
what you know Wes is a friend of mine
too he's from from Baltimore he thinks
it's [__] funny it's just it's
hilarious but um so anyway I discard
tried to run me over and beating me
swerved at me beeped and gave me the
figure I was like what the [__] so I go
to I stopped the skateboarding on my way
down to the beach Santa Monica at verdeo
drive and I grabbed the beer and I'm
sitting there and I'm looking I look at
the out the window of the of the place I
see the car
the the I thought ran me over try to run
me over so I went out my schedule smash
the windows out of the [__] thing
went back over to sat on the curb and I
got arrested got taken away that was it
that's all that happened
when I was I did 10 months in Twin
Towers when I got out with evangelism or
whatever so when I get out of there I
look on the internet now prior this was
2017 18 I think I had never been on the
internet never Twitter none of that [__]
so my son when I was in jail called me
or I called he said dad some actress uh
matter of fact the cop told me you're
the most famous man in the world right
now so we talk about is that Corgi smash
was an actress so her name was Jamie
King I didn't know this I didn't know
anything whose car was I just know that
it was the car that swerved at me that's
all I know I know I know I know cars so
anyway so I I go on Twitter and I'm you
know and she's bashing me she's saying
all this y'all the homeless the drug
addicted homeless is in this town also
and I'm looking at them pictures I said
I know this [__] chick and what
happened was I it's it's Jamie King I
didn't know her like that but I hooked
up at one time at the Roosevelt in the
bathroom so anyway so that's probably
why she swear to me but they never to
this day even asked me so they're
bashing me Paul Francis Floyd's birthday
that was an adopted name of mine the
homeless vagrance not that he's Jim
Morris's kid that he's [__] he's got
music all this [__] [__] but a lot
actually was on the internet at the time
but my point is um so I when I get out I
I make a Twitter account because I want
to snapshot these things she's saying I
want to start you know getting into this
social media [__] so if I put my album
cover on it's me on a tombstone it says
[__] hell and I water and I and I
but the first time I ever put out there
in my whole life this was only in 2017
that I was even Jim Morgan's kid I never
once mentioned it to anybody except for
people that knew like Mario up here in
California there's people I'm getting to
the point of how I know how everybody
knows this
um so anyway so kid rock hits me up on
Twitter he's like yo I bullied it I
texted me at this number I'm like Kid
Rock I'm gonna get the [__] out here so
I started taxing but first I didn't
believe him because of the account
wasn't verified but he did explain to me
he said I know you don't know I'm like a
[__] with [__] like I'm so far behind
when I put my mouth dude I thought I was
getting cassettes made and they were
already up to mp3s I swear to God well I
could have 200 million dollars in the
bank right now in BMI I don't even know
what my record sales are because it was
mp3s and uh and but I know 100 of it
anyway [__] so I so Kid Rock was
start talking I feel like he had six
months or so we were talking and so I
had mentioned him about Gwen and he says
yes or whatever answer he tells me Gwen
needs three months
you know what I mean she wants to meet
with you but she needs three months uh
you know she wants to quit she's going
to quit the view she's gonna quit her
residency in Vegas and she's going to
break up with this Blake guy she's
watching a year or whatever oh my God
whatever so and of course is that three
months I was it there's a there's a
little spot down there on Sunset
Boulevard La Brea there's like a little
apartment complex Cher used to live in
there actually now it's like a mental
health thing but I know people living
there so we were in their party and [__]
whatever one day and Nikki six of them
guys were doing the dirt and the guy the
one guy John that his name is John he's
he was a he was the uh guitar player for
Mega Death the original one uh he's all
been in that shape anyway because they
they fired him all the [__] he lost
everything but anyway so he's in there
and he comes in with this guitar he's
Nikki's guitar and I was just I just I
just text I just uh messaged Nikki too
like a minute before that anyway what
goes down as soon as he comes in and
he's like about this guitar and I know
he's taunting me and I know damn right
well the Nick he knows where I'm at
because I just I just and he said to me
did you just Message Nick yes yeah so
anyway I know John's here it's gonna be
promised me so he joins in there now
prior to this some chicken some chick I
found out was one tricked me into taking
a dick pic by myself
whatever so John says that was most
important he says you know that dick pic
that you have I'm like what are you
talking about John he's like the one
this one I'm like yeah he's like well my
girlfriend he's or my my old lady I'm
like who the chick from the push that
thousand again he has a kid with the
singer from The Pussycat Dolls I was
like what about her John he said well
she seen I said what you said I have a
small deck he's like yeah so all this
[__] goes down and then next thing we're
going back and forth and I didn't know I
just got an iPhone 10. I uh and I didn't
like I said I'm I'm not real good with
this technology but the phone was on it
was recorded I didn't know this at first
so we get to John's like I'm like what
would she have a small dick so we're
going back and forth to this y'all like
John you know your dick's probably some
always look oh it is a dude after you
shrink all this [__] so then he says to
me you remember Tommy Lee and Pam
Anderson's uh video of their sex video I
said from like 30 years ago yeah he's
like you ever see it I'm like you know
and see these guys know this about me
they probably know they knew that I
didn't see it so he's like why are you
looking up so I [__] it up and I'm
laughing I'm like oh if I'm like I got
him beat by [__] you know yeah
everybody but anxious you know it's all
this [__] so we got into this joking
thing about Tommy and Pam and their
video and what ended up happening was
that video was stuck on my phone somehow
or maybe did or didn't a week about a
week later I get a phone call from a guy
or he hits me up on the Instagram
account he says I'm Bryce Wagner he says
uh Jim or a bull that is yeah Jim Jr yes
on Bryce Waggers I'm a director for
Netflix he said I I
um I'd like to know if you'd be
interested in doing a movie he's uh your
storm eater can't I see the stormy what
are you talking I didn't know I had an
IMDb they they made it for me he's like
you're storing me to come up he says uh
the movie's gonna I'm gonna do it about
you it's called Uh Rockstar's forgotten
children
he said because you have forgotten about
my brother he says you actually what are
you going this was before I even knew
about anything Jim Jim let me ask you a
question yeah do you use drugs uh
occasionally I party
sometimes yeah because that's all there
is to do and you know here and there
yeah I'm not like an addict how do you
support yourself
right now yeah I just
I mean Gwen's been sending me money a
little bit here and there Gwen Stefani
sends you money yeah a little bit here
now but I mean just to keep me on and
Wes Wes Scandal was posted I mean 20 or
any other day but that got jammed up
because I thought it was uh something
going on but I mean I got friends that
are to help me out but right now Gwen
she bought us but supposedly I don't
know if she still has that I think she
said she never sold the house up on the
hill that's what we're gonna do we're
moving into
I know it sounds crazy but trust me it's
not dude it's not it's not [__] so
what ended up happening was uh Bryce
says you know I'm gonna make you do a
movie about you I said I don't I don't
really want to do that I said but if I
can marry going Stefani and then it'll
be cool so whatever and then what
happens I now I did that video somehow
got to to uh Jamie King's bodyguard
because he was following me around and I
what happened was I'd seen this this uh
start comes up it said
security for the stars come up on my
Instagram and I sent a text message to
Trump because I'm a disabled veteran and
I'm in a combat veteran Navy and I sent
my ID my military ID to Trump even
because I know he's been here and you
know I'm not ashamed to say it I said
Trump I said I said Donald who is this
here in Hollywood who are these people
like I don't need security so I I sent
the text off and the reason I said that
because the cops when they arrested me
put me in prison you ever met Donald
Trump no I've not no I I know of them
I've never met him but I've seen them on
jobs I'm a union carpenter so I've seen
I know Trump down from the Taj Mahal
when he built in Jersey he's something
else dude this is a lady who had a
little house little little baby thirty
thousand dollar house it was in the way
of the building and Trump's Trump
offered two and a half million dollars
plus a place for the rest of her life
and living in Charles Mahal she said no
he built right around her we had to stop
the whole job at a shutdown so you met
him once no I never met him I've seen
him I've seen him before but I'm not I
never met him the only reason I sent it
to the president is because you know
it's my right is it I didn't know how
[__] slimy these cops are here so I
sent a picture of my ID and said
whatever I got a uh something back or
not doesn't matter I know it went to him
you know what I mean and what happened
they started photoshopping [__] they
they photoshopped and twisted up the
[__] message sent to the president so
anyway so this bodyguard so I said I hit
him up I said I don't need no I don't I
appreciate but I don't need any kind of
security you know he's like no I'm Jamie
King's Bible was there is there a
problem or something you got to get him
even you're obviously follow me right
you're on my [__] Instagram I don't
even know how to [__] works
so the guy said turns around until he
calls the cops well Jamie can't even
call the cops and said that I threatened
him with this video that I he said I
sent him a video I was talking about
Tommy Lee and and pamel Anderson's
[__] sex tape of my dick so what else
he told rockstar I was talking about
Dick sizing guitars you know I mean
that's all we're talking about and
[__] uh so he's like uh
you know you threaten him with this
[__] video you said it's a sex video
and at the end of the video
you heard because John said something
stupid and I went over and smacked the
guitar off of John's last Nikki's guitar
because I told him I said I don't care
the guitar is a piece of [__] and then I
knew it was [__] I knew what he was
doing it was taught me I know Nikki was
probably I'm sure Nikki knows about it I
know Tommy did because Tommy and pan
then they re-released their sex video
after I went to jail over the [__] after
the prince it's a big joke is Jimi
Hendrix your uncle huh is Jimi Hendrix
your uncle yeah I call him my uncle I do
because he was best friend with my
father my mom
yeah I called my uncle and had they
survived they would have been Michael
you know what I mean I do say I do call
him my uncle I do I say Uncle Jimmy all
the time I do
nothing wrong with that what about Elvis
Elvis Presley what about oh well I don't
know you know West scan like if all
places to get kicked out and get
arrested he got kicked out of Graceland
I'm like what what the [__] what's that
what for what do you do I could see him
I know he is he probably went in and
[__] in the bathroom I was dying there
something I jumped in the shot I
guarantee it was something like that so
[__] funny I think it's a trick but I
compared you know I do I now Wikipedia
to ask me this because I'm an author I
mean believe it or not dude if you if
you go if you that one picture I showed
you it has a picture of my dad because I
put in one time what is you know who is
Bullet Head Jim Morrison's son
because I because like I said I was born
Jim Morrison Jr and there's nothing
about this oh they sort of call me
Bulldog but that was just because
you're called bullet head because you're
a shot because I got shot and I did the
album where did it hit your brain I went
in within my temples within my science
cubes it was in my science chapter I was
behind my science cavity and my eye my
eyes swell up and I went into the
hospital
and you know so we can't do nothing you
come back up so every day I had to go
back for like two weeks till the swollen
went down all the [__] take it in the
box and what happened was when they got
when they took it out they put a little
incision I went on Howard Stern actually
too over this and he said it was the
biggest pain in the answer in history of
the show because I wanted to say
anything about it but anyway so they
took my they took the board out of my
the doctor said to me I swear to god
dude he was like uh let me ask you a
question he's after the surgery was like
a short you know short procedure he says
uh do you have a cocaine user I said
well I should hit it pretty hard in the
80s why you know like why and then
[__] my mother Karen the [__] the
the birth mother she's with me and we
don't get along we never did I knew
because she's [__] she's a liar she
holds information anyway I know I know I
said right away she's gonna start
bitching me about doing drugs in high
school right after his operation she's
like I [__] knew that's what you were
doing that I'm like shut the [__] up man
I'm like why doc he's like because when
we pulled the bullet out he thought when
he first went in it looked at it he
thought it was an infection around it
because it was a white part he said it
was a bowler I swear to God the ball of
cocaine stop the [__] bullet it was
in my science guy so he said to me I
swear in my life that's what the doctor
told me now I I know because I know
people that snort like their pills would
have uh like Percocets they're not
oxygenous mixed with amphetamine or
whatever it is it's Tylenol it's only I
know people who snort them and every
once in a while they blow out a [__]
chunk of that [__] so that's that's what
happened the cocaine start the book
anyway back to today so so the whole
time the whole and you know even like
like Gwen
she she's been around longer than you
wouldn't think because I I'm not even
one my song called move a girl is about
her and her in her Hollywood Video
but uh simple with that so they call her
call me Bullhead but it was actually the
name of the album I mean I should have
been featuring Jim Moore's news which
I'm doing now but there was I did see on
the internet someone somewhere a few
years ago had done that and it says that
you know presenting I think it was Gwen
because uh she you know she she one does
a lot one's a powerful woman dude let me
tell you something yeah I don't think
people understand that Glenn is a
problem she's not gonna be taken lightly
it's like this this lipstick company
that she did that's because of me
because I heard that did I matter of
fact I was just talking to this chick
today Kylie Jenner you know it's all
about Kelly whoever is Kylie Kelly so
someone told me
uh I was just this morning matter of
fact before my phone died she was just
messaging me I said uh someone said to
me you know Kylie Jenner's a billionaire
I said a billionaire I said is that Ms
Bruce Jenner's uh
daughters yeah she's a billionaire for
what did she do they said well she has a
lipstick company that's a lipstick
company
the [__] I said if anybody should be a
billionaire because of literally it
should be one because if you think of
one back in a day what do you think of
red lips and police Bon Air right so I
said that and what happens I go to jail
so for the four years and I'm oh she she
even sent her computer her webmaster
came into the [__] prison to talk to
me and told me the reason they did told
me the reason that they said I was
homeless is because my ID my California
ID had me to watch I didn't even goes
out of Pennsylvania I did which they
took from me the [__] anyway it
had an address on where a lot of
homeless people go see that's probably
why they called you homeless
here's what he said to me and I said
well I don't give up actual Facebook
when I said skateboarder I didn't say I
don't care put this at home is
background so anyway I said I didn't
know nothing about that someone told me
when I got here because when I first
came out this time I was just staying
hostels and [__] or not hostels yeah and
hotels but um it's got to be frustrating
for you having a father whose estate is
probably worth millions
I just feel like [__] and he's all over
everybody and my mother's Janice Joplin
and you're living homeless
again yes and Quincy and Gwen could stop
it tomorrow but she's got her own agenda
I understand and Gwen like I said she
she's got a lot of things that she's got
to make sure we're right for her because
and tell you the truth she told me that
she got raped by these [__] blacks in
the music business because I started a
bunch of [__] about that too because you
know who Shane Paul is you ever heard
that guy no okay well he does is Light
My Fire doesn't it it's a shame Paul
this [__] dude his record labels in
[__] Jamaica for one he comes up and
Light My Fire well I don't give a [__]
dude you know what I I I've seen I've
seen a videotape myself I said dude I
don't know who you are I said but I tell
you one thing right now you got going my
old lady's name on your [__] on your
fingers I don't know who what's going on
here one won't [__] tell me nothing I
said because she she wants me wrong
about I said it's going to come around
full circle dude that's the only thing
I'm telling you right now is no one in
50 [__] years is [__] with the doors
music okay
that was a real good friends absolutely
told me a lot about my dad absolutely
and Mario married to a matter of fact
the old man but I have to get their last
name up here at the Rainbow Room Mario
to pull me out one day he said oh
there's somebody here I want you to talk
to this this lady is older lady
I said Dad she says hey how you doing
she said she starts going into this
story she says your father used to
babysit me she said to me she said I did
see my picture I don't look out of my my
dad's critic so I don't research the guy
okay I'm his son not his critic I am a
lot like him in many ways I write like
I'm not actually they call us both
world-class writers or some kind of
thing I forget what it is but anyway
here's a picture of him with his little
girl I wondered if that was her it
probably was I've just seen that
recently anyway she says your father
used to babysit me she says uh we did
you know she said there was a store down
the street
I guess that's the one it's up somewhere
up in the long Canyon I guess whatever
yeah supposedly there was a store and it
was the guy who worked there was like a
deformed deformative or whatever you
know people get like often tires and
you've seen people like deform that's
who the guy was and they had a pet
monkey as opposed to show me in the
store so actually he says this is
there's a story where the creatures meet
you know what I mean uh yeah uh she's
got she's got monkeys lazy time instead
of funkies that's where that comes from
so anyway she said he comes back from
the store to get down to get candy for
her and he had something in his hand
handed to her it was his love Street
love Street and he said to her
do you think people will like it she was
six years old and he said you're not
gonna love it Jim so that's you know
that's supposed to worry about I like
you know it's it kind of touched me and
I mean I was like that's cool you know
so then I asked us do you have anything
else I mean you know like I'm interested
oh dude I always knew my dad's leather
pants were somewhere the ones that he
wore for like three two years whatever
was dude I'm like I know dude I got a
prison I'm like I'm gonna get it I said
she [__] married this [__] guy she
was supposed to break up but I'm
thinking myself I'm like [__] man so I'm
like I didn't even know the thing was
recorded it's on the internet so I'm not
seeing it somewhere I made some TGI
Fridays because I knew my dad finished I
seen him there and this funny thing is
dude let me just give her I know I'm
probably giving a lot of information
it's funny because there was Frank
Zappa's pants and my dad's pants now why
is that I don't know but prior to coming
out here I was standing in the Poconos
Mountains in Pennsylvania I'd moved up
here from Philadelphia from King of
Prussia and I stayed with this lady who
I met who had a room in her in her
little cause she said I can run it out
so because I was trying to get away from
my probation officer out there a little
bit and that's going up there for
probation was easier so one day she
comes after me she said all right Mr
Rockstar she goes who's this
you know she's not she's a computer but
she's still a Beyond at times too you
know I said I don't [__] nice too
she'll look at I said watch your husband
Frank he's dead I never met she said
yeah well who's the other guys I don't
know she said he's in rock and roll I
have no [__] idea I said I don't know
Bob Dylan she's like no it's like Frank
Zappa her father supposedly in 83
zapping on a Hiatus he won
away from everything for example was a
he was an interesting guy you know I
mean he everything he did that's why he
never got regular time because he was he
would he was like me he's like I [__]
it up in a second if she's an
opportunity I'm gonna [__] it up just
from not meaning to but just you know
there's so much to tell or whatever so
anyway
um so I that's the first time I ever
contacted Robbie I don't know why so she
told me that Frank used to live with
them in that house a matter of fact he
was he was Frank was friends with her
for her husband who was a professional
boxer back in the 50s so that's how that
connects but she you know I heard he
don't drink and smoke that's [__]
she he was a closet drinker he would
High bottles everyone and [__] all this
weird [__] yeah he wouldn't let the food
couldn't touch each other he would have
pillows and like sheets brought in so it
was just
so anyway I uh for some reason I decided
you know what because I was on my way
out here that's what it was and it took
another serious for me to actually get
out here again so I I hated I looked up
Veronica because like I said I was just
getting on the [__] internet at the
time I said let me see if I can find
Robert crude areas he's on Twitter I
want the doors to be remembered as and
he's like
I want the doors to be remembered as and
I'm like yeah a dude and I'm like and
you know yeah and he's like and the
funny thing is because now I know they
all know about me I didn't know that
they didn't even dreaming Jonathan had a
kid so this is all this was back in 2015
so I'm like I'm not watching I'm like
he's like I want the doors you
remembered as a cosmic force in this
universe you know that yada got all this
[__] that you know it wasn't we weren't
we weren't ruled by the [__] front
man this drunken causing problems all
the time the rest of the band doesn't
cause the pro all this [__] I'm like
this [__] I'm like how about
this Rob however you remembered as a
[__] as a [__] rock and roll back
I'm on my way if I got there right
because I so I got an email address then
I hit him up I even said I said how
about you he remembers to rock a robot
if I'm a boy the [__] out there so I'm
getting more just kiddos you don't know
if you know know who I am yet I said but
if you I said for sure I said but
ironically enough I'm staying in the
house and poking on mountains in
Pennsylvania did Frank Zappa stayed in
when I get out of here I just happened
to walk on the Hard Rock Cafe and
there's [__] Zappos 11 pants in my
dad's I'm like what the [__] so anyway
when I get out of jail prison I go to
prison all [__] afterwards are you
staying in a tent no [__] no where do
you where do you sleep I seen it I put a
couple people that I know there are
places or whatever oh you do I I have a
few friends that have performance [__]
you know I just I don't I'm not going to
go [__] even after that I don't even
go up to the Rainbow Room [__] but West
was supposed to come get me I don't know
what the [__] did they think it's a joke
even flee flee are you tight with any
other celebrities
but I do they know who I am because I'm
on when when Gwen and uh no doubt put
out their uh what do you love most about
Gwen what I love most people I I love
about wine is is still with the way she
is dude she's just she's funny
when I first seen her back in the day
man I was like what the [__] I don't
think they were on MTV or VH1 I was like
did Tommy Lee [__] no you mind you I
knew who I was but I'm I'm living a
normal life you know I mean I want the
Navy After High School I was a carpenter
you know I was working I had kids at
Brandon was six months old my oldest was
so I got to tell you something about
that so Brandon was six months old my
oldest who the [__] oh no that was after
that's what I said but I've seen him for
the first time that's right she was in
her [__] muscle shirt her uh her
[__] boyfriend I'm like did Tommy Lee
die a champion [__] lips like I
really thought that's what he did
because uh Brett Michaels has a sister
named Tracy who I actually was uh took
my virginity actually believe it or not
back when we were 15 she she was that's
another whole nother story she came she
was in a bad girl's house in our in our
neighborhood anyway so I and I knew that
he's you know they did like bread even
like he would wear makeup [__] so I
thought and then it was Gwen well I like
about going I like the way she do she's
she's a tough girl man I'm telling you
she's she's [__] she's smart she's
funny as [__] and she won't let you know
she you know I mean like
she just I don't know there's a lot dude
she's fine it's like it's like this
company is literally coming she starts
what do you think she loves about you I
think she loves everything about me I
mean that's what she tells me I mean I I
my father is now if my father if I
wasn't talented if I wasn't if I didn't
do music if I wasn't she's spending a
lot of time with that dude Blake if
she's married to you
well how much time she spent on them it
doesn't even matter who can understand
he's a gay I don't even talk about that
she's he's gay he's not like he's not
it's funny because I told him that in
fact I could show you my phone in my on
my Twitter so when Blake hits me up and
then from what's from his his account
you know I know his account and his
obviously there's a second but then
there's another one but anyway [__]
he's like
uh something I'd want to talk I said
well that's fine too we do need to talk
like I said because I've been putting
all the [__] on the internet dude
there's like 17 or 18 guy pictures of
him kissing men okay I don't care that
you're gay that's fine dude you're
beginning to disclose it for one okay
see this is what you gotta remember I
just found out that they weren't that
she married me a couple days ago so all
this whole time I thought she actually
didn't matter I'm like what the [__] you
just found out what a couple days ago
she just told me because I kind of
thought that I said why would you why
would first of all the share the whole
shame there's so much I don't remember
marrying her no I wasn't I wasn't
present that's what I'm saying I was in
prison
yes yes and she told me the other day
she was going to she was gonna have to
say put something out on the internet
about it she would see I mean she was
but she's beneficial I'm like on my bank
account she could have easily [__]
one married us that's what I'm saying
she said Gwen can do whatever she wants
dude it doesn't matter she's world
[__] world [__] power she's got
world powers dude I'm telling you she's
not there's like 30 [__] one matches
all over the world like she's she's not
a joke dude
she's a very powerful person dude I'm
telling you
she is she's the only I can say whatever
one on a hurricane I can make I have a
counsel to her in her their official
accounts of hers and she sends me
information and I you know she puts
accounts together if you go on choreo
you know that is oh there's an account
she made you know that was made up for
me there it was already made up and it's
all about you know and even her LinkedIn
if uh you know I I trash her dude I
trash her a lot of times I do talk talk
[__] about when I talk about live tour
[__] lover I call aren't you because
that's what the [__] you put yourself
out to be in a nice ground if you're not
it's fine but the thing is now you got
this [__] excuse my name and I know
the whole n-word pistol about but [__]
you if it does because my whole thing
was with that was what I was saying
about these [__] black kids or
they're in this [__] music business
dinner and most of them are black I
don't care I feel you I'm not a
Prejudice but I'm saying most of them
are [__] black they're not all black
but they're all [__] in my opinion
you're taking pieces of people's [__]
music put it together and you're getting
away with it you're not making money
that's the thing you're not even making
money you're just getting followers on
[__] YouTube you're not getting paid
because of YouTube no disrespect I know
you're making money off it YouTube's the
reason that the music business is [__]
up when Tommy Conwell or Tommy uh Patty
put that uh the last DJ marketing
directors started on YouTube start
YouTube YouTube will tell you if you did
a copyright infringement notice we'll
tell you how to get around it I sent a
copying friendship notice to Gwen and to
Interstate Interscope and [__] Shane
Paul to him but there's no use because
his [__] his labels in [__]
Jamaican she didn't even know that so
anyway
um
you know the industry took it down but
the thing is it doesn't even want to
think that my point is no one for you
you're you're a piece of [__] you
[__] you're out there and Gwen's in
your video now oh dude I call a saw a
concert with that but Gwen knew that and
the thing is
like I said she's not done she lets me
wrong my mouth the way I do because she
doesn't I don't know anybody she was
right by she was right by the industry
she was raped by the [__] blacks and
the [__] industry now you want me to
try to guess he was freaked by knickers
okay and she [__] she was okay she
won't tell me who it was and you like
it's Dr Dre SLL ass [__] Diddy I talk
to all of them I haven't sent a video to
doctor I said I don't give a [__] how
you how they're going to take it out
here but I'm going to be niggering this
[__] now I see this it's a it's a
point it's a fact I'm sorry I think
we're good all right I believe it all
except for the Kid Rock story what about
Kid Rock I'm Just okay I'm sorry I
didn't mean to be yelling like that man
sorry about that again I get worked up
that's a hell of a story